welcome back tuesday edition of pft pm
shereen williams mike florio and we are
very pleased to be joined now by john
mclean of the houston chronicle
this is a difficult subject matter but
it's important to get someone like john
who's got the experience
and the knowledge of the houston market
and the dynamics there to help us better
understand
how all of this is being reacted to and
digested locally so john we appreciate
your time and let me just start with the
story of the day we're now up to 16
lawsuits
we've become aware of another one during
the commercial break what's been the
general reaction
by the average houstonian to what as of
a week ago
we knew nothing about well first of all
mike and shereen thanks for having me a
week ago at this time
most of the fans were mad at the texans
for
creating issues that would cause watson
to want to be out so bad
and then when watson and busby used
social media
for the first time on tuesday night that
caught everybody
by surprise so right now everybody's got
an opinion
on it as you can imagine everybody waits
every day
for the next shooter drop so to speak 16
now tony busby who like rusty harden
is a high-powered well-known houston
attorney
two heavyweights uh squaring off against
each other
but right now people are still kind of
in shock
john uh what is the texans view on this
they have not
said much other than you know we know
it's out there
we're waiting to see whatever just a
blanket statement
how do you think internally though
you're there you
you know what's going on in that
organization how do they view all of
this
and and what's going on with desean
watson well i can tell you what they
think because once david
culley had his meeting with deshaun
watson
on zoom three weeks ago and watson
reiterated
why he wanted out after colleen told him
what the plan was to rebuild with him as
a centerpiece
they made a plan behind the scenes they
were going to trade him
they were going to get through free
agency and then all those teams that
have been calling
nick casario the general manager he
would get back to them and the idea was
that multiple teams would be bidding for
watson who has a no trade clause
and that they were hoping to maximize it
and ask for three
ones two twos a defensive starter and if
somebody wanted to throw in a
quarterback that would be fine but the
idea was to try to draft
in the first round another franchise
quarterback and that's all
gone down the tubes now because nobody's
going to make the trade
anytime soon because they're not going
to be a resolution anytime soon
do you know whether the texans john have
any idea where this is going from a
league
perspective the nfl clearly is
investigating there are various options
available to the league office under the
personal conduct policy up to and
including
placing deshaun watson on paid leave
that would be the ultimate irony here
at a time when watson has said i'm never
going to play for this team
again and never be paid again obviously
by the texans
there's a way these dominoes fall where
he's on
the team not on the roster getting full
pay
not actually allowed to play for the
texans
and there's nothing they can do about it
other than cut him
well they're not going to cut him mike
and you're right when you wrote on pro
football talk about the commissioner's
exempt list and what that means which is
just what you said
they have just started the investigation
tony busby said all of his clients up to
16 now
there's talk that it could be as many as
24 they will cooperate in the
investigation
then they're going to have to talk to
watson people on his side
and so the texans don't have any idea
what's going to happen
and it's going to come down in every
instance it was he said
she said there was never anybody else
around according to the lawsuits
and so i would be surprised if this ever
goes to court
as an attorney mike you know how these
things play out
and and i'll tell you this the texans
are waiting to see
what happens but i don't see any way
watson ever plays there again
and i'm guessing there's some team that
would pop up
before the draft and lowball them and
say we'll take the problem off your
hands because
they know eventually it'll be behind
watson he'll play again
and he'll play great
john you know as journalists we don't
ever get to really
know pro athletes but we know them
obviously better than fans do and we're
around them and you see them and you see
them out in public
and you know how they are in the locker
room and elsewhere how surprised were
you
that desean watson was associated with
with everything that's come out now up
to 16 cases
well i'll say that shereen i know
athlete's a whole lot less than i used
to
before the nfl puts such heavy-handed
restrictions
on the media and our and the uh
time we're allowed to be around players
in the locker room
i know the water is a whole lot better
than the texans but still
i've covered watson since the day was
drifted and i was shocked
i still am every day i'm shocked and
i've not tried to say i think he's
guilty or innocent because he's innocent
until proven guilty he deserves to be
heard the women deserve to be heard as
well a lot of people have opinions he
has direct detractors
he has supporters and i'm trying to keep
an open mind about it as we find
new allegations every day
yeah john that's been the challenge look
i'm very respectful of the legal process
i understand how it works criminal and
civil
it takes time and there are presumptions
and protections that apply to someone
who is accused
but in the court of public opinion
there's no requirement that
people withhold judgment there's no time
limit for when you can come
to a an opinion as to whether or not you
think someone did what they're accused
of doing
and one thing that stunned me over the
course of the past week is
just the way that this has
been a landslide against watson with
everything busby has done and i've got
concerns about some of his tactics
but in the court of public opinion busby
has mopped up the floor with the watson
camp and even today i don't know what's
your
what's your overall reaction to the way
they've handled this up to and including
the statement that came out today from
rusty hardin
rusty harden is the attorney to the
superstore athletes and at some point
i think he'll be firing some broadsides
that are much more effective than what
he's done so far
i think he mentioned in his statement
about
they don't know who they are they're
jane does they only
know one because according to a sworn
affidavit
from buying bernie who then brian is is
watson's marketing guy
that uh that the first that the first
plaintiff tried to blackmail them
according
to watson bernie and rusty harden but
i'll guarantee you rusty hard and at
some point when he collects
more information and he's ready to come
out with his own news conference
and take on tony busby in the court of
public opinion
he will do it
john you've seen a lot in your 30-plus
years i don't even know what you're up
to now but of covering the oilers first
and and then the texans have you ever
had a year
like you've seen over the last year with
the firing of the head coach and the
hiring
jack easter be running the organization
and then you get a new gm
and then now the desean watson stop from
wanting to be traded to these 16
lawsuits it's just been an unreal year
have you ever had anything quite
like this in your history in houston
well i have in 45 years of covering the
nfl
um we had 1993 with the oilers a player
blow his breeze out during the season
we had baby gate we had buddy ryan and
kevin gilbride
but that was during his season in team
one the worst season i've ever covered
was the last year 1996 when the
wilder's last season in houston before
they went to nashville that was like a
funeral
every day but that was no fault to the
players or coaches
in this situation you have like
something
almost every day you wait to see what's
going to be next will it be a player
will it be a coach david colley new
coach nick casario new gm
they want to start the new era this is a
rebuild it seems terrible
they're going to be worse before they
get better and they thought they were
going to be able to get a franchise
quarterback
out of a trade and i guarantee you
they're not going to be able to do that
anytime
soon but things here are bleak as you
can imagine
and getting bleaker by the day yeah john
this is the 20th season since the texans
joined the nfl
and they feel like an expansion team for
the first time
since they were an expansion team all of
the transactions over the course the
past week all of the new players the
turmoil the upheaval
from a football standpoint i don't know
what to expect but does it feel to you
like
this is just a brand new team starting
from scratch
26 players have signed uh one-year
contracts they've only given one
three-year contract and that was to a
punter and they've got
new players in almost every position
mike and it's exactly like you're
starting over
it's almost like nick casario's six year
30 million dollar contract
has got a bonus for transactions how
many players you can bring in
a one-year contract but the team was
terrible last year
and he knows it he's been a personnel
man his whole career
and so he is trying to out with a bad
and hopefully end with a little good
but all we know in these one and
two-year contracts
some of the guys won't be there when
they go to the 53-man roster a lot of
them
won't be there at this time next year
but they're trying to make them more
competitive
and help their special teams but now
you're going to have
to ride not tired to rod taylor is the
starting quarterback barring injuries
and injuries cost him his last two jobs
at cleveland in the los angeles chargers
so they got a big issue and what was the
most
important and best position on the team
with watson
yeah john you know owners are trying to
make up from all the losses last year
from the pandemics so they're counting
on
full stadiums but i can't imagine you're
out and about in the community all the
time
i can't imagine that houston fans texans
fans are excited about this team and
they're expecting full stadiums how is
this going to affect
obviously the on-field product is not
expected to be good but how's it going
to affect stan
fans in the stands and the recovery from
the pandemic pandemic
by the team before last season they'd
sold out every
game going back to the first preseason
game in 2002
and their president jamie rhodes who was
responsible for the business side and
did a great job
in the community selling sponsorships
club seats
suites uh everything he resigned
and they've got a credibility problem i
wrote last week this
is the worst credibility problem in
texas history
and the third worst i've ever seen to
when bum phillips was
fired by the oilers in 1980
and when they moved to nashville this is
the worst i've
seen and only way you're going to build
that back up is show some progress
and fans are hoping that nick casario
and david culley can do that but man
right now
they don't have a lot to work with
back to watson and let's just summarize
so everyone understands what your
opinion on this
is you still believe he'll never play
for the team again
you believe he'll be traded at some
point do you have an idea of when you
think that transaction will be
feasible for the texans and for a new
team
mike for several weeks i've been writing
i expected him to be traded by the april
29th
the first day of the draft and now five
quarterbacks are expected to go in the
first round
if they waited until after uh say the
trading deadline next season there and
some quarterback gets hurt
they're not going to get near what they
could have gotten before this draft if
they wait on next year's draft they're
not going to get as much
i think maybe a team will give them
conditional picks say hey we'll give you
a one
this year and a three next year and they
say okay but let's put some conditions
in there
get another one and a two i don't think
you'll be cut
i think as you mentioned earlier he'll
get paid
if he's on the exempt list the only
thing i know about this situation
is there's not going to be a resolution
anytime soon you guys know how the will
of justice turns
and you also know how nfl investigations
how long they take
because they're so comprehensive so this
is going to be a topic we're discussing
for months hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports